i think that that brexit has played a
part it's played a part in 1.4 million
european workers who left because of
kovid went home not coming back with the
enthusiasm that we would have hoped
that's a big hole in the workforce but
it's also the case that covid has
accelerated lifestyle changes which
people were making anyway so a number of
people something like half a million the
bank of england says have decided to
become economically inactive they've
chosen to give up work because they
liked their lifestyle during the
lockdowns and after the lockdowns and
then you've got a change in the
character of foreign students in the uk
who before the 2016 vote were
predominantly european and eu citizens
who chose to work their way through
college and often in hospitality or
other jobs associated with the food
supply chain now many of those students
are chinese in origin and they don't
work their way through now all these
changes are social changes which have
have have happened and probably would
have been would have been happening
anyway they've been accelerated and the
thing that we need to grapple with and i
think george and the government need to
grapple with is that these changes may
well be permanent and if they are
permanent that means there's a gap in
our workforce that we need to address
and the immigration policy that was
designed for a different kind of
workforce pre-brexit in terms of policy
making is now in my view not fit for
purpose
could we have seen it coming
so i i think on the
could we have seen this particular gas
price spike coming not necessarily but
that you know wholesale energy prices do
that so we could totally have foreseen
that that things would
would go up from time to time and it has
played into some underlying structural
weaknesses in in the uk energy sector
which you know we we could have chosen
to fix for sure
uh
dale vince do you think that we could
have seen particularly the gas uh
the gas spike coming
i think we could i think we've seen it
before
i think the fact is for me in the energy
market it's neither brexit nor covered i
think the north sea is running on empty
we're down to about 50 percent of our
energy now from the north sea so we're
much less energy independent than we
were at its peak we've seen that coming
for decades
in this particular crisis we had two
nuclear power stations go down they
didn't come out of scheduled maintenance
at the end of the summer at the same
time the summer was the least windy for
60 years so our wind fleet which picks
up
30 percent of our national supply now
that underperformed we have a cable that
connects us we have six cables
connectors to the continent one of those
burned down so we couldn't bring
electricity in from france all of that
created an electricity shortage and so
we turned to gas to fill the gap at the
same time as the rest of the world was
turning to gas that's ultimately the
problem and the russians have turned
down suppliers to europe by 25 for
political reasons so but but it starts
fundamentally with a shortage of
electricity that we have which is a
structural one and then we turn to gas
at the same time coincidentally as
everybody else